mai nur unsere feinde ich den sieht auf
hindi urheberrecht
mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einer neuen episode von
lukas leute stunde ich habe vor einiger
zeit einen beitrag auf seite eins
gesehen wo es um einen jungen ging der
mit einer schweren krankheit zu kämpfen
hat seit einem jahr hat der 13-jährige
moritz in aggressiven tumor in seinem
gehirn und im hintergrund lag einen
smiley kissen aus meinem shop daraufhin
haben wir kontakt mit der familie
aufgenommen und moritz vor einigen tagen
überrascht und zu hause besucht sondern
habe ich moritz gefragt was er gerne so
viel videos auf einem kanal schaut und
er hat gesagt ich würde ganz gerne
moritz gefallen meine reaktion auf video
anwendungen von euch daher habe ich mir
gedacht reagiere ich heute mal wieder
auf ein paar witze von euch doch bevor
ich jetzt gleich auf die witze reagiere
möchte der moritz noch kurz jemanden
grüßen
die klasse 8a favorisieren die
englischlehrerin wird auch gedrückt
ja okay jetzt geht es los mit dem video
war lukas leute stunde geht es darum
dass ihr meine zuschauer auf instagram
videos posten können unter dem hashtag
lokal in dem ihr ein witz erzählt und
das habt ihr vor einer woche schon mal
gemacht nachsagen steven rack ist
scheiße die flasche ist ausgelaufen ja
mal schauen ob die witze diesmal besser
sind nie heißt lukas
kawka
der sohn die mutter mama rief die mutter
antwortete daraufhin ein wachsen der
sohn sagte daraufhin ich fange an zu
kochen
in jedem fall viele wölfe
den fand ich sogar grün das ist echt
waren sie da kommen uns ersten typ an
der irgendwie sagt kavka was so der
komplette schwachsinn einfach ist dann
kommt ein anderer junger der sagt seine
mutter würde nicht kochen und der dritte
wird bei dem ich dann wirklich sache ist
einfach nur nennt man viele wölfe
wolfgang
also mein humor ist glaube ich echt
querschnittsgelähmt
wenn die preise steigen
ihr seid doch das denken
schlechten rasen kann man nicht wegen
herzrasen hh
wow
kein herzrasen nicht mehr kürzen schule
am schatz ich fühle mich in letzter zeit
zu retten täglich braucht dringend ein
kompliment juli zu lukas eine gute
beobachtungsgabe
wisst ihr
als ich wenn diese serie überlebt habe
habe ich mir gedacht da kommen wirklich
rasse witze an wo sich leute wirklich
gedanken gemacht haben stattdessen werde
ich einfach nur fertig gemacht
denn da steht sogar auf fotos
geil alter hat er meinen merge rumliegen
aber beleidigt dann meine mutter und
meine mutter bei aldi force ist am
nächsten tag alles 18 treffer geil alter
kaum hast du vielleicht noch in deine
mutterwitz für mich jemand eingebrochen
und natürlich bruder geil freut mich ein
stimmiger gute witze hier wieder
ich bin
du wirst vermöbelt wenn du bei ikea
klaust kriegen wir zwei sätzen
kriegen sich zwei graz in die haare auch
umringt
da verstehe ich dass mich mal eine dicke
frau ging zur bäckerei sie mein tipp
schweren kugeln der bäcker antwortete
darauf aber nicht in meinem laden wird
kannte schon
was ist gelb im profil wenn man es hier
ins auge schmeißt
ja
was
ach so ja da hätte ich auch drauf kommen
können was sagt spanier der taub ist und
ja sagt
sie
also das wird für den witz da bekommst
du wirklich von mir den ring der woche
herrschaften sehr hoch geplant sagte
eine ostern zurück der andere ist es
wasser geben dass wir noch nach
hhl mir vier körperteile aktien als maul
aus gesicht also
das ist bei mir leid also
zu beginn von sonderfolge ist das kreuz
levels ck hier weil ich mir halt denkt
okay da ich muss mir wieder witze
anhören und am ende ein erfolg ist es
schon hier so also wir sind gerade ca
auf der höhe kann sich mit grüßen
nein und können ausländer kein
fußballspiel weil sie kein pass bekommen
ich fühle mich scheiße dass meine
mundwinkel dabei so ein bisschen hoch
geben ich hoffe ihr versteht das hier
alles nur spaß ist und dass wenn jemand
sagt deine mutter irgendwas dann geht es
natürlich nicht gegen meine mutter oder
wenn er sagt ausländer bekommen keinen
pass so das ist als alles nur humor so
also wir sind nicht gegen ausländer wir
sind nicht gegen frauen nicht gegen
mütter nicht gegen keine ahnung war es
fragt das kind den vater papa wo hast du
denn hier habe ich als kinder ein
gespendet ob das kind entführt und wieso
denn antwortet der vater damit nicht
besser wohlfühlen straße gemein
das ist wirklich gemein aber irgendwo so
lustig
in russland wirklich so krass ich glaube
das ist er dieses typische stereotype
denen die nicht loswerden so wie die
deutschen nicht loswerden dass alle
denken dass wir wie die bayern sind
somit lederhose und birnen
na da bin ich ja gespannt die klasse 5a
schreibt eine klasse denn fragt yamaha
was fragt der tim denn den jona kann ich
mal ein finger haben nun das fragt warum
du hast doch selber ein das frage ich
mich jetzt tatsächlich auch ich weiß
aber meiner macht so viele fehler
oder nicht oder nicht
das war dein witz warum fragst du mich
dann oder nicht ich habe diesen
zugerufen dass man belegt achtung kacke
wer dir denn der humor geschossen luca
du bist ein schatz du gehörst vergraben
die so
wie sehr ich gerade mache meinen usk
runter gefallen dass ich kann sie nicht
ausgehen mithin urheberrecht vor nein
nein
ach du scheiße
was tue ich mir denn was passiert wenn
luca ein laden betritt es geht sofort
dann auch mehr
[Musik]
ich liebe die
tochter claudia sag mal was vorsingen
daraufhin antwortete tochter ab die
gäste schon angehen sagt die mutter
stimmt aber dann schnell genug gehen
sitzt hätte ich tatsächlich schon
allerdings in einer gewissen anderen
ausführung
also erzählt weise so witze werden ja
dann oft irgendwie anders weiter erzählt
allerdings sehe ich dass das video noch
ein bisschen länger geht ich bin das
mädchen aus dem letzten video maschine
er war moment
die treppe runter
nein
ich sage die stimme wer von einem
kleinen jungen gewesen als
wiedergutmachung werde ich dir jetzt auf
instagram folgen hier ich bin mir grad
gefolgt sieht man das ja es ist es
fokussiert das ding sich willkommen
häufig videos eingesetzt wo sich leute
nicht selbst filmen wollen ist natürlich
auch völlig verständlich hat auch keinen
bock meine herzliche fresse abzufilmen
auf jeden fall kann ich da nie genau
zuordnen bei gerade stimmen von kindern
ob das jetzt eine junge oder mädchen
stimme ist
als er sie sagt sogar noch was kauft
lukas ein mensch weil er braucht geld
weil er muss sich alkohol
ja
sie sagt ihr sollt man das kaufen
keine schlechte idee ist
allerdings sagt sie danach dass ihr nur
mein merge kaufen sollte damit ich mir
shampoo leisten kann weil ich so stinke
isch en folgte gleich wieder wenn luca
sich schneidet ist er dann ein
schnittlauch
lustig
ganz ehrlich dieser gerät noch hat mehr
kästchen ist während sein das
ist definitiv korrekt leider
[Musik]
weil der film erst ab 18 ist
dafür bekommst du einen applaus die
nennt man einen dünnen frosch
magerquark
alle kinder gehen auf toilette packen
außer frage der schweiß in den schrank
kann ich dir doch mal höheren energien
aus bettlaken aus der scheiße in den
schrank
endet der witz ist so ähnlich aufgebaut
wie dieser wolfgang wirthmann viele
wölfe
mussten wir richtig stumpf einfach
runter gerattert feiere ich aber war
dass das zweite mal dass ich dieses mal
wirklich gelacht habe mit ihm gibt es im
supermarkt oder im supermarkt gab es
eine aktion der 500 begründet muss nur 1
euro für den einkauf zahlen fritzchen
war dessen platzte aber er hat sich
leider nur ökonomie für 79 cent
gebraucht
ja
könnte auch ich gewesen sein an der
stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat und
euch diese serie lukas noll stunde
gefällt das gerne mal ein leichter
schaffen 40.000 like dass eine hohe zahl
aber das zeigt mir einfach hey luca wir
feiern das wie du dumme auf witze von
einer dummen lu crew reagiert ziemlich
dumm alles tatsächlich falls ihr irgend
einen lustigen witze haben dann filmt
euch gerne und dadurch das video auf
instagram mit dem hashtag lokale hoch er
mir könnten auch gern folglich heißt der
laser luca und dann kommt die eventuell
in die nächste folge von lukas leute
stunde
[Musik]